- So, what do you think,
you going to kill us?
- I'm going to do my best.
- Might not be in the game.
- In the game, no.
- Hey guys, so my name is Johnathan Wendel
also known as FATAL1TY
I'm a 12-time World Champion video gamer.
Pretty much one of the most deadliest
people on the internet.
- The YouTuber here named RUNJDRUN,
and I love playing
games like Call of Duty,
Halo, and also Super Smash Brothers.
- Hi, my name is David Lonigro
I'm a former United States Marine Corps
Special Operations Sniper.
I served six years in a
special operations unit.
I've actually never played
Call of Duty before.
- I'm Mikal Vega, I spent
22 and one half years
in the military, half in bomb
squad half in seal teams.
- So we're going to play
two on two deathmatch game.
Where basically you have two veterans
versus two professional gamers.
It's going to be a very interesting battle
between the teams and
we'll see who's teamwork
comes out on top.
- I think I have a lot of real
world experience, obviously,
so I feel like that will hopefully
translate well to the game.
(weird music)
- Oh you can jump over stuff right?
- [David] Let's do it bro,
alright throw a grenade and pull.
- I don't want to do
that, put that shit back.
(gun shooting)
Ah!
- F and G down.
- You should be proud.
You should be really proud.
- Did you get all the damage?
- [Johnathan] I took a little damage.
- Yeah I got a couple of shots off.
I'm proud of myself.
- He kills me, he's so fast.
(shooting)
- Ah!
- Eat it.
- Wow, he's real close, got him.
Payback!
- [Johnathan] I'm pretty
happy with how I did.
- You guys did pretty good man.
- I got five kills.
- Well I don't have any kills,
but I got a shot off though.
- Alright, round two.
- From behind, again.
Did you stab me or shoot me?
- I just shot somebody.
(shooting)
- See they're moving as a unit, dude.
This is like, horseshit.
- I just get moving
tactically and I get hit.
- Oh, what?
- [Johnathan] Did I get the grenade?
- Dude, that almost killed me.
- Dangit!
- I gotta get one kill man, come on.
Oh oh, you motherfucker.
- Knife.
(laughing)
The F and G almost got his first kill.
- I almost did but you know what
I choked, I hit the wrong button.
- [RUNJDRUN] You actually almost had JD
you had the jump on him.
- [David] He's like running behind them
and then he runs into the fountain.
- What, you think that's
pretty fucking funny, uh?
(laughing)
- You guys ready for one more?
- Where the vets at, where you all at?
I'm coming for you.
- So what you're saying is you're
happy to be killing vets?
- No, no no.
- Is that what you're saying?
Is that what you're saying?
(shooting)
- [RUNJDRUN] Ah, you got me.
- Bitch.
- Nice shot.
- Thank you.
- [RUNJDRUN] That's a pro kill.
That one kill represents the whole game.
They won, because they
killed a pro player.
- Payback.
- Somebody just, there it is.
Who else is?
There it is, somebody threw a grenade.
Ah, fuck, where's it from?
No it's from the top.
Where you at?
Ah, shit.
Ah, there, I got murdered.
Alright, we lost, or well,
we won but,
God but that was nothing
compared to last game.
- I mean we got crushed.
I can barely use the controller.
I feel like I was PT and
jogging around the whole time
and then I squeeze off a couple of rounds
and I get killed.
(laughing)
So that was my experience with
these professional gamers.
I don't know what Mikal
would like to add to that.
- You got to pick those small victories,
like getting a kill.
- It's actually pretty
impressed that we know
that the final game we
played, you got two kills.
You killed myself once,
which was an awesome kill,
and you also killed JD once.
So, you can see the progression
of them getting better every game.
- I can't wait till we
get to the gun range.
(laughing)
Now that's our arena.
- The F and V, the F and V.
- Now, you two are the F and
Gs over at the gun range.
We're going to be shooting
M4 assault rifles,
so, we'll see.
- I didn't talk any shit.
- That was them making
up that F and G thing.
- [Mikal] We should check that playback
on how nice he really was.
- [RUNJDRUN] I was pretty cool.
- [Mikal] Hey, are we
acting like we didn't
get 20 kills the last time.
- [RUNJDRUN] That was just me
talking about the game, hey.
I was just talking about the game, man.
(laughing)